[音楽]
夏はいいですかこれじゃねカップ焼きそばの方が完璧より好きって人っていいって言う
と思うんですよ
9後にも1人いますで見てもらって分かると思うんですけどあっペース張って
ものすごいは売ってるわけですよね代表といえばこのペア&とか言うほどと思うんです
けれどもそれ以外でも本当にで美味しい焼きそばっていうのはこのようにターン
草生んだというわけで私こと1週間かけてなるべく売ってる間別の片っ端から集めて
これだけが集まりました
それより今日の動画は私今日お腹が空いていますってもう普通の焼きそばを食べ
秋ターンしてほしいもっとおいしいや草を食べたいそう思って私は思いついてしまい
まし
ああああああ
たっ800止まってはそれぞれ味の特徴があるんですよこれを全部混ぜて食べるは静雄
最強においしい今まで誰も食べたことないようなおいしい焼きそばができると思ってる
んですよ
これどうでしょうか良いと思いませんかでじゃあ今日は僕の場合にあったもう全身の
カップ焼きそば一つにまとめて地上最強人も一緒に焼きそばを作っていこうと思いま
普通では目ましょう外で何バーガーペア月は誰もが知ってる有名な役様です美味しい
です何待つよ
に4月の ufo の濃いソースが特徴ですねめちゃくちゃ有名です美味しいです
ナンバースリー後つまりソース焼きそばたまに見かけますからこのマヨネーズが
美味しいんでしょうねキューピーさんですからね美味しいです中ファーを再びへ4 s
ことが恋だしそう
だしがきいてソースっぽいですね美味しいです
多分ナンバーバーイ昔ながらのソース焼そば
キャベツが入って5倍増しですね美味しいですなー発生
一平ちゃん夜店の焼そば腸脳こそ
鉛筆に夢ですねちょっと濃厚ソースポイントに楽しみです
美味しいですナンバーせ一平ちゃん夜店の焼そばはい悲しマヨネーズで有名ネットです
ねちょっと辛いですけどそれがまた美味しいんですこれめちゃくちゃ有名ですなあ
あああ
富士宮やきそばこれ静岡の富士宮っていうところに客層がすごい美味しいんですよ直下
ちょい持もってすごい人気ですこれおいしいサーバーっマルちゃん正麺焼きそばま
美味しいですナンバーちゃスーパーカップまっ方面固有満杯し max ん
美味しいですナンバーグライダー突破が流行しそうそうも焼きそば美味しいですよ
総選挙ほしいです勝ってマルちゃんやきそば弁当これ北海道にしか売ってない前節の
焼きそばですソウルフードといわれます美味しいですって言う今までき
ついたと思うんですけどもここにある約様全部美味しいんですよ
ビックリ本当に一つのほらぽいシーンで今度それぞれのハーモン指で合体させて個々の
性格及ぼすことなくやっぱ約様のお客様で悪いくれないことは絶対ないと思うんですよ
お互いがお互い尊敬しあえる干渉しあわない関係に辿り着いたその先にある全然との
焼きそばそれが今日の企画お互いの良いところを吸収しあう安倍相場という英語
救出
デミがあるんですけどもそれでその鍵合わせてやてぃ総武
作っていこうと思います
0号
[音楽]
橙ディングと別鍋洗います
で今回はモテってバレて1個ずつ作るんじゃなくてるぜ中身ぶっこみます
jr
ok でスポーツ回復だけ全部取ってあとは名誉全部するとここに打ち込みます
me
[音楽]
多いのはいつでも同じエピ側なのにこんなに色が違います面のびっくりはじめもよして
国からはないように火薬と頭差があるんでうまいことは分けていきましょうねこんな
感じですね
あんまり美味しそうじゃないですこれからお湯をぶっこんできますからこれが全部
引っ張るほどあるかどうかちょっともらいますけどがんばりまーす
強いはねたら火傷しちゃうようん
戦前ありないとでヤバいかこれ大丈夫
小山ですんじゃねーかねもっとわからなきゃ maja 真島じゃあ患者なんじゃね
これちょっと待ってた後ほぐして7分感じるあなたはもっと下に入って焼いも3分たら
どうかよくわかんなかってそれ
大変本当にこれどうする五爪の形だけはしっかりとほぐしてしまいいい自分の敵が
ほぐれてしまうわ
平和じゃないし世界になっちゃうあなたたち does の穴タイプ論来てねは1分
起きなけれ前
大変ですけど所
[音楽]
adobe に神と意外となんとかなってるかこれ大丈夫相談がイベントいいはずなん
でこのままも入っちゃいますだ絶対にどの面もいい感じに柔らかくなって欲しいにここ
しっかり混ぜないといけません
頑張りますも焼きそば作りっぽくなってきたよそりゃそういうさあ急いや水やそいやっ
さー
水ようそ
スタッフ
つラプスに萎えた用資料が生んだけどもういいショー at
どうやってどうやっていっ
何も考えてなかったどう過ごす俺だ理論が正しければ
果たしてこのじゃあ育ったようなために良い館できると思うよねいきます
大丈夫でしょ以上所を申しますまあこれは完璧な水切りが今目の前で行われております
ごでしょう全く改悪も落ちません面も落ちませんもう計算されたこの鍋の机にダンゾウ
をするしかありません私
ん
あの7分かかるのでしょうか
もういいのかとあっつ指
まぁたぶん大丈夫でしょさあここから勝負です何とマヨネーズを曹操がたくさんで
片っ端から入れて完璧にやすさをつくっていきましょう
a
これできまー
ああああああ
あっはぁっはぁはぁなんでとくらい
攻めで売れましたあれ俺は思いついたああああ
me
anf
あっはぁし
me
運営というわけで大変お待たせいたしました
こちらが肇社長の周りに打っているカップ焼きそばを全て混ぜて作った
史上最強にして唯一無二のカップ焼きそば
[音楽]
考えを忘れました焼き総武だっけそんながです多分
開会とうえで常に感染しました結構ねロール飾ってると思ってるのかね見てもらって
分かると思うけどめっちゃ綺麗に混ざってるんですよそして壁に貼りック解約等いや
もうなんかソースの音聴き方の次元がね今まで捏造活用と思うんですよねこれを任せ
致しますこちらが唯一無二して衆生最強のかペストばヤンキー
総武ですかハッハー
香りかーっ
花粉症でよくわかりませんがからしマヨネーズも入ってたり結んの二にくいから感じ
られるスパイスの数々としていく泰蔵氏にも大量の要素が含まれていて全く味がみち
ですでは早速いただきたいと思います
[音楽]
いきますさあどんな違うんでしょうかもう運者には分かりませんが味を楽しみたいと
思いますいただきます
んだったん
ん
[音楽]
えっ
うーんまえって合致れる甘いずっ
うーんま先生なんか全然焼きそばの要素を含んでるんでどんなずに似てるとかあの言え
ないんですけど美味しい焼きそばの味ですねほどよく酔いからめぐってたと言って
ちょっと甘めで美味しいんですよなにこれ
ああっいやっめっちゃ美味しかった本当に本当に味が無限に広がって感じで800は
までて来なきゃいいな
ふと気がしました何て言えばいいなら協議しづらいなぁ c で味の表現をするならば
屋台の焼きそば
[音楽]
me
バッハ
3食べれないなぁ